Hello and welcome to this first video where we're going to be looking at behavior trees.
Now when we're working with behavior trees we're going to be working with a whole load of new
classes and I think it's useful for us to kind of compare these classes to what an actual
sort of a human would have at any one point because with AI what we're looking to do is
mimic a sort of form of intelligence so that we can control the NPCs or the non-playing characters
within whatever game we're working on. So the first of these classes would be the behavior
tree itself. Now the behavior tree can be thought of as the brain. It is a visual way of organizing
the sequence of tasks and their dependencies. So this is going to be how we automate the thinking.
So you can think of that as the brain. Next up we have something that's called the blackboard
and this is directly connected to the behavior tree but this functions as its memory. We are
going to be loading data in and out of the blackboard and using it to make our decisions.
Now the next thing that we have is a task. Now a task is a action. So this is something that
we're going to be asking something to be done that can be placed within a behavior tree.
This is a bit like a function when you something that you call within a a pawn or something.
However it is it is an active class in itself therefore acting to be quite modular so that it
can so we can repeat them and use them in different ways against different different pawns.
Next up we have is a decorator and this is going to act a bit like a filter or a sort
of decision maker. So when you look at behavior trees and we're going to quickly look at how
a decorator might work this is going to prevent us from doing certain paths or actions.
I always think of it as a filter. Next up we have a service and what a service will do
is it will regularly check certain conditions and these can be saved out as variables or saved
to the blackboard but it functions as a checker so it's constantly just checking
that something is true or of a certain value. Now before we jump into the project and have a
look at the behavior trees I wanted to show you a couple of animations so that we can get
a kind of visual idea of how the behavior tree works. So as you can see here we have a whole
load of different nodes all connected up tasks decorators sequences and services.
Now when the AI starts off it's going to always start at the root here at the top
and it's then going to follow down through the left most path and depending on if you've got
a selector or a sequence it's going to action the tasks accordingly. Now we talked about
decorators and we described them as those kind of filters. Well you can see here when we jump
into the second graph if the decorator was going to filter or gate off this different path
it's going to mark this entire path as a failed path and because we're using a selector at this
point it's going to go on and it's going to use this path on the right hand side.
So this is just sort of a very quick visual interpretation of
the order of how the different nodes are going to be followed from a behavior tree.
Now we're going to build something like this through the exercise so you're going to get quite
accustomed to it but it's just nice at the beginning to be able to see this sort of
visually how this is going to update. So that's what we're going to cover for
theory about behavior trees to start with. In the next video
we're going to be jumping into the engine and setting one of these up from scratch.